let's show her if she doesn't want to
show up she doesn't want to work she has
too many boundaries she's out you heard
that right
Kim and Chloe are ready to fire Kourtney
from Keeping Up with the Kardashians I'm
just like living life and whatever
happens happens but I'm not like
thinking about I'm not putting my energy
there let's rewind it all went down on
Sunday's episode of the family's reality
show when quartz little sisters noticed
what looked like a hickey on her neck
and court refused to dish the deets
about who gave her that mystery mark on
your neck my hair is here no you have a
hickey on your neck yeah Kim and Chloe
weren't going to let Kourt get off that
easy
my sisters are pretty nosy when it comes
to anything in my life and I try to keep
certain things private I don't like to
share about you know dating that's when
in true Kardashian fashion Kim and Chloe
channeled their inner detectives
borrowed a friend's car and followed
Kourtney yes I am serious maybe she's
interested yes that's the ho mobile
where is she going why are we going
did we just pull up to some random house
she's wait she's getting out she's
getting out Wow look at her outfit
what's unclear anyway Kim and khloé
ambushed court at the private residence
where they thought she was meeting a
mystery man and needless to say court
was mad what do you think you're doing
shamefully how do you think it's funny
I'm having a meeting with who for couch
yeah so Court wasn't there meeting a
mystery man she was there for business
I'm not literally dating anybody but we
don't know cuz we don't know anything
about you what if I actually was then
what like you bring the cameras here
it's so disrespected like it would be on
camera if I have boundary ISM respect
that then things went from bad to worse
because Kim took a look at a survey
taken from Keeping Up fans and according
to the report fans felt disconnected
from Kourtney because of how little of
her life she shows on TV I'm not
surprised that the report says that
people don't feel like they know the
real Kourtney because sometimes I don't
think I don't know and that's when they
decided to FaceTime court and threatened
to kick her off the show if she doesn't
open up more we'd have a proposal for
you it starts with an F and ends with a
D Savage everyone needs a consequence
let's show her if she doesn't want to
show up she doesn't want to work she has
too many boundaries she's out well the
girl sat down to hash it out I think the
private moments are so special and I
just need more of them court explains
that she feels like she's given enough
to the show over the years and reflected
on the impact the show had on her
relationship with Scott Disick she even
implied that the stress and pressure
from sharing their love on TV may have
been a factor in their split my
well-being is more important than the
show
I'm not giving in kind I'm not going to
change my boundaries yeah so Court
walked out on the convo and things are
still up in the air between her and her
sisters but when et caught up with the
girls in October Court had this to say
about the rumors she was leaving the
show you mentioned that you might be
ready to say goodbye to Keeping Up with
the Kardashians
where are you out on that I'm just
decided to spend more time as a mom and
you know put more of my energy there but
I'm not saying goodbye do you think the
show can continue going if you lose a
sister we definitely love Courtney and
we will miss Courtney and whatever she
decides to do but people come people go
all the time this family we are feel
like it's a revolving door so Kourt you
might leave this week she'll be back
they all come back something tells me
that Court is not gonna go anywhere but
you can count on et to help you keep up
with the Kardashians so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Holly Stephens see you soon
[Music]